well i think that's the thing we got to
look at today tom is command from vince
he didn't have it in cincinnati's last
start
imperative against his lineup that he'd
be able to command his pitches
another one-two curveball hit the
opposite way miller to his left getting
tested
and he throws out trey turner
and a call strike three on the outside
corner
wind-up and velasquez the o2 to bell
swing it a miss struck
him out high fastball got him
nationals going bullpen day and they'll
look for at least
a couple innings out of austin another
payoff pitch
breaking ball tapped right side
starlin castro in the shift one away
and then blows the four seamer by him i
like his versatility a guy can come in
give davey a start when needed
trey's going after this foul pop and he
has it stays in play
and austin vogt with a smooth one two
three
bottom of the first inning
out to center field o'dooble didn't see
it right away but is able to close
easily
and make the catch one out
out to right field harper's going back
he has room he ran to a spot that makes
the catch for the second out
and the one one on the way swinging the
ground ball towards third right at bowm
he'll go the short way to second
and they'll force out avina
truck out 63 times tied for third most
amongst national lakers breaking ball
ahead of the air
to center it was a cutter coming on is
robles a couple of steps in makes the
catch
1-2 swing and a miss austin voth
coming out looking sharp
another good curve ball this one popped
high into shallow right field
soto in as mercer couldn't find it juan
soto says no problem
now both squares around the pond as
they'll try to sacrifice
roblox to second here's the pitch
and that one got austin vote in the face
austin votes squaring to bunt
and vince velasquez struggling with his
command here in the second inning a
terrifying scene here in philadelphia
as austin both will come out of this
ball game and the bases are loaded now
for juan soto here's the 1-1 swinging a
ground ball left side it's through a
base hit into left field
roblox will score robles ross to third
will hold rbi single to left for juan
soto
swag tied him up with a fastball
swag and a miss he got him 94 miles an
hour back to back strikeouts
and the o2 pitch hopped up
back at first hoskins going back here
comes harper and reese makes the
over-the-shoulder grab and the inning is
over wow
just one run scores in the inning
jordy mercer levels off and rips one out
to left field
this little bounce off the wall and
jordy mercer has an extra base hit with
one away
great swing by jordy on a fastball
elevated
that's now three hits for him in his
last two appearances
and we'll give roblox a chance still
looking for that first hit since he came
off the il
cracked in the air to right center field
deep this one is crushed way back
they're not going to be caught and it's
off the wall
mercer will head home and score robles
is in at second with a booming double
his first hit off the injured list is an
rbi double the nationals lead two to
nothing over the phillies
taking off bro gets away and the
nationals will have their third run
on a throwing error from jt real muto
well that's why davey martinez loves
victor robles
great call by davey too trying to find
ways to score runs for
your team when you're scuffing a little
bit at the plate
this one tapped right side jordy mercer
will charge and flip
for the first out he fly to center his
first time runners on first and second
one out reece
pops it up over near first
bell backpedaling mercer's there too he
dropped it
it spins out of his glove and goes to
right field everybody is safe
mccutchen is up got struck out his first
time
loop down towards center field row blaze
is coming on he's not going to get it
read beautifully by hoskins or run
scores
it's a 3-1 ball game he's 3-2
it's taken inside ball for another run
is home
brad miller with the bases loaded walk
into score is harper
and it's now a 3-2 ball game let's take
it and here's alec baum where the base
is full
again the 3-2 pitch coming
[Applause]
for another bases load walk that ties
the game up at three
ronald teres popped to right his first
time up
but he bounces it over to third
backhanded by castro to second
not in time everybody is safe mccutcheon
scores his 1000th run of his career
and the phillies take the lead it's 4-3
matt joyce is going to pinch hit for
vince velasquez and now the o2 to joyce
it gets away here comes miller and
miller's going to score
finnegan never came home to cover here
comes odubal herrera he started this
inning with the ground out
and a bouncer pass castro down the left
field line that ball has some eyes
two runs score and the phillies add on
it's a
7-3 ball game
back towards second base miller to
second for one can they turn two
they can a four six three double play
that'll bring up brad miller miller who
drew a bases loaded walk
his last time up her ball hit in the air
right field that is
watching that is a moon shot
into the second deck whoa
brad miller two-run home run
9-3 philly's on top
[Applause]
this one's driven hard brad miller makes
a nice play
hit right at him but he loved it cleanly
avila will come in to score
so stevenson brings in a run
trey ground ball left side and through
rbi single for trey turner has made it
nine to five here in the sixth
a high drive to dead center field back
on this one herrera to the warning track
he leaps at the wall can't get it
it's off the wall carrying towards
center field turner's gonna score
soto on his way to third as harper picks
it up and throws it in
soto slides into third with a booming
triple it's now the phillies nine in the
national six
big opportunity to get a couple more
runs in here jt
romuto is the battery
[Applause]
extend their lead back to the top of the
order for trey turner
has gone down this is this is a pretty
impressive operation going on here
look at this fingers crossed the music's
playing it's going back up
yes sir this is unbelievable 20 minutes
21 seconds
swinging to miss the inning is over an
eventful hitting it was
is ready to go the 2-2 pitch swing and a
miss he
got him the ball game is over and the
phillies have taken two of three from
the washington nationals